how does the voting system in the
Council of the European Union work the
council is made up of member state
representatives who meet regularly to
adopt and discuss EU legislation
decisions at council meetings are taken
by vote the council can only vote if a
majority of its members is present 15
out of 28
there are three types of voting
procedure simple majority qualified
majority and unanimity simple majority
voting is used for procedural issues
such as the rules governing council
committees it requires the majority of
member states 15 out of a total of 28 to
vote in favor of the proposal qualified
majority is used for the 80% of EU
legislation adopted through the ordinary
legislative procedure also known as Co
decision a qualified majority is reached
if two conditions are met
55% of Member States vote in favor in
practice this means 16 out of 28 the
proposal is supported by Member States
representing at least 65% of the total
EU population this is the double
majority rule proposals can be blocked
by a group of at least four member
states representing more than 35 percent
of the EU population this is called a
blocking minority not that complicated
but wait there's a catch this qualified
majority rule is in use from November
2014
but until 2017 Member States can still
request to use the previous rule under
this rule each member state has a
certain number of votes based on their
population size reaching a qualified
majority needs 260 votes out of a total
of 352 from at least 15 Member States
now for your Nana mati I guess it's
pretty self-explanatory
it requires everyone to agree or abstain
if a councilmember abstains the other
ministers can still reach unanimity
unanimity voting is used for some
specific areas mentioned in the EU
treaties such as citizenship EU
membership and Taxation after the
council votes on legislative texts the
results are immediately made available
to the public now you know how voting in
the Council of the EU works find out
more on the website at Concilium dr.
Roper dot EU